المترجم: Mo'az Galbat
"وأنت ماذا تعمل يا أبو حميد؟"
هذا شكل صاحب والدي
ونحن نتحدث لمدة نص ساعة تقريبًا
قبل أن يسألني ذلك السؤال--
بعد..
عندما يكتشف أنه أضاع نصف ساعة من وقته
يتحدث مع شخص كل عمله
أنه يصنع الألعاب.
أنا اسمي أحمد نجيب؛
أعمل مطور ألعاب.
ووشريك مؤسس في 2024 studios.
لكن قبل أن ينظر لي أحدكم
نفس النظرة السابقة
دعوني أقص عليكم كيف حدث هذا.
هل لعب أحدكم Mario أو Doom أو علاء الدين؟
جميل،
مَن لعب Prince of Persia؟
هذا الإصدار، ليس الأخر.
أنا من ذلك الزمن الجميل،
منذ طفولتي وأنا مهووس بألعاب الفيديو
لم أمل يومًا من اللعب
كان باستطاعتي اللعب ليومٍ كامل
لا أفعل شيئًًا أخر سوى اللعب
ولا أشعر بمرور الوقت.
الشيء الوحيد الذي كان
يوقفني عن مواصلة اللعب، هو المذاكرة.
لم تنطلي عليكم،
هي لم تكن المذاكرة
لقد كانوا يوقظوني بعد أن تطيع
مفاتيح لوحة المفاتيح على وجهي
لكي أنام على سريري.
المهم، من صغري وأنا مدمن
للألعاب، حتى المرحلة المرعبة؛ الثانوية العامة
المستقبل، مجموعك،
القلق الذي عشناه بسبب أهلنا.
فبدأت بتقليل وقت اللعب
ضمنت دخول كلية الهندسة،
ورجعت مرة أخرى لألعب.
تخصصت في هندسة الكمبيوتر
وكانت تلك نقطة التحول فى حياتى--
ليس بسبب تخصصي
ولكن بسبب صدور لعبة skyrim حينها.
هل لعب أحدكم Skyrim؟
هل يفهم أحدكم ما أقوله؟
Skyrim لعبة قلبت الموازين في 2011
عالم مفتوح، ما يعني
خريطة كبيرة جدًا
تسافر فعليًا لتذهب من مكان لأخر
وتعيش فى عصر أسطوري؛ تحارب التنانين
وتتحكم في كل شيء في الشخصية؛
بدايًة من نوعه حتى أسلوب القتال
وكيف يحارب،
تريد اللعب بساحر أم بسيوف
عالم أخر.
فهمت حينها
لماذا انجذبت لألعاب الفيديو
من المؤكد أننا جميعًا نحب مشاهدة عالافلام؛
أكشن، خيال علمي، رعب، باختلاف الأذواق
لكن كل واحد منّا يريد أن يعرف
ماهية قصة الفيلم
الفكرة من الألعاب أنك
تكون جزءًا من تلك القصة
أنت الذي تتحكم في مجرى
جميع الأجداث في اللعبة
أنت جزء من ذلك الأمر.
حتى أنه يمكنك أن تتحكم
في حياة أموت شخصية معينة،
أنت جزء من التجربة.
وقتها علمت ما هو الشغف،
علمت معنى "أنني وجدت نفسي في هذا المجال"
معنى أنني مستعد للتضحية
بكثير من الأشياء التي أحب
من أجل شيء واحد،
ليس بالإمكان أن لا تكون جزءًا من حياتي
فقررت؛ أنا سأصبح مطور ألعاب
بدأ شغفي يكبر
وفضولي يزيد
وبدأت بالنظر إلى الخطوات؛
ما الذي أحتاج معرفته
لكي أصنع لعبة فيديو؟
فوجدت أن هناك ما يسمى بمحرك الألعاب
وهو عبارة عن مجموعة من الأنظمة
تستخدم سوية لكي ننصع اللعبة.
قرأت أشياءًا كثيرة،
معلومات كثيرة لم أفهمها
أشياء كثيرة أعدت قراءتها مرارًا
لمجرد أن أستوعب 60% منها
لكنني كنت سعيدًا بكل معلومة جديدة أتعلمها،
كنت سعيدًا لأني كنت أحب الموضوع جدًا.
شعر أصدقائي بذلك الموضوع
فقالوا: "أتعيش قصة حب جديدة؟"
لا، ولكني علمت طريقي
علمت ماذا سأعمل.
للأسف، نحن كشعب مصري بطبعنا
نحب أن نسخر بسبب وبدون سبب
من يتفق معي في هذا الموضوع؟
أشكركم!
"إذن ماذا تسعمل يا نجيب؟"
"أنا سأصبح مطور ألعاب"
[يضحك ساخرًا]
"حسنًا، ربنا يوفقك يا حبيبي"
هذا كان أول جزء..
الجزء الثاني كان أفضل قليلًا
لأنه على الأقل سمعني
"ستصبح مطور ألعاب؟!
فلتجد شيئًا يمكنك من العيش"
من المؤكد أنه ليس من ألطف الأشياء
أن تجد أناسًا من نفس سنك
تفكر بذلك الأسلوب
لكني كنت متحمسًا
وقررت أنه ليس هناك مشكلة، سأكمل طريقي.
لابد أن أحدهم جُنّ
وفكر نفس نفس تفكيري.
بحثت فعلًا ووجدت شركتين في مصر
يعملون على تطوير الألعاب،
قليلين ولكن الحمد لله نتيجة جيدة.
قرأت عنهم أكثر
ووجدت أن شركة منهم أفلست وقفلت
والثانية أخر خبر سمعته
عنها كان منذ 8 شهور،
وعندما راسلتهم
لم أتوقع أن يردوا عليّ أساسًا.
إحباط شديد!
لكن لا مشكلة
سأكمل بنفسي،
وبدأت أفكر في أفكار ألعاب
وبعد أن أتخرج، ربنا يسهل.
وقتها كان أكثر ألعاب مشهورة
Cut the Rope وAngry Birds
فوجدت أن الناس تحب الألعاب
التي تتضمن الحركة أو مبنية على الفيزياء
ووجدت أيضًا أنهم يحبذون
ووجدة شخصية لطيفة في اللعبة،
لكي يجذب الانتباه.
حسنًا، سأسير على نفس النهج.
أناس كثيرون يحبون الكلاب
فسأحضر كلب صغير مثلأ
وذلك الكلب تاه من صاحبه مثلًا
ولكي نرجعه إلى صاحبه
سنضعه في فقاعة
ونطير تلك الفقاعة بمجموعة من
المراوح والمكانس
الشي الطبيعي الذي يحدث كل يوم!
لأنه لو صدق الناس
أن ضفدعًا يأكل الحلوى
سيصدقوا أن الكلب يمكن أن يوضع في فقاعة.
بالمناسبة، وجدت هذه الصورة على الانترنت
فعلى الأقل أنا أتحدث عن شيء حدث قبلًا.
انتهيت من الكلية، وعلمت أن
ITI تقدم دبلومة في تطوير الألعاب
وجدتها، هذا هو أول الطريق.
والحمدلله، لأنه كان فعلًا أول الطريق
أولًا لأنني كنت وسط أشخاص
لديهم نفس حماسي
يملكون نفس الاهتمامات ونفس الشغف
جميعهم يريد النجاح في هذا المجال
فكنا نشجع بعضنا
وكنا متحمسين لأن نتعلم وننجح.
الشيء الثاني أنني بدأت
بمعرفة أشياء أكثر عم المجال
ولكن بمنظورٍ احترافي أكثر.
بدأت بمعرفة أدوار كل شخص في الفريق،
هناك شخص يسمى بمصمم اللعبة
وهو المسؤول عن توقيت صعوبة وسهولة اللعبة،
الـgame artistالذي يصنع الـ3D models
أو يرسم الصور أن كانت اللعبة ثنائية البعد،
المبرمج وهو الذي يبرمج
طريقة تصرف كل شخصية،
وبطبيعة الحال كل دور له تقسيمات أخرى أصغر
ولكن على الأقل
أن الصورة بدأت بالوضوح أكثر.
مشروعنا في ITI كان
Puppy in Bubble
اللعبة التي حدثتكم عنها منذ قليل
شيء رائع جدًا أن الفكرة
التي كانت مجرد رسومات على ورق
وأنت فى الكلية تتنفذ أمام عينيك.
قدمنا هذه اللعبة في مسابقة Magic Cup
التي تنظمها Micosoft
وحمدًا لله، حصلنا على المركز الأول في مصر
وتأهلنا للنهائيات في سياتل.
وقتها، كنّا ننهي ITI
فكان الفريق مجهد ومضغوط جدًا
جميعنا يحتاج إلى الراحة،
وأصبح تقدمنا يقل جدًا
فأصبت بالتوتر،
لكن المشرف على فريقنا
كان رجلًا عبقريًا،
جائني في أحد الأيام وقال لي: "لماذا أنت قلق؟
نموذجكم الأولي رائع جدًا،
وفريقكم ماهر،
ويكمّل أحكم الأخر، وليدنا ما يكفي من الوقت
لكي ننتهي من المشروع"
وفي الحقيقة قال لي جملة
رنت في أذني
قال لي: "You have no excuse to lose"
ومن تأثير هذه الجملة عليّ
كتبتها على جدار غرفتي
وبالطبع عندما رأت والدتي هذا المنظر
أرادات أن تطردني من البيت
ولكنها وجدتني متحمسًا
فتركتني.
سافرنا فعلًا،
ووجدنا أنفسنا ننافس
فرق من بلاد كثيرة جدًا
وقتها انكسر عندي الحاجز
"عقدة الخواجة"
وتعلمت درس مهم جدًا في حياتي
أن كل واحد منكم لابد أن يعلم
أنه ليس أقل من أي شخص أجنبي
كما رزقهم الله بعقل
رزفنا نحن أيضًا بعقل
ونتسطيع أن نفكر بشكل جيد
اتفق معكم أن هناك بلاد كثيرة
قد تكون ظروفها أفضل منّا؛
ولكن من يريد النجاح سينجح.
أتحدث خصوصًا عن مجالي في الIT
لأن أي شيء تريد أن تتعلمها
ستجد جمبع محتوباتها على الانترنت
فلا تقنع نفسك بأوهامٍ غير حقيقية.
جاء يوم إلان النتيجة
والحمد لله، حصلنا على المركز الثالث.
والحقيقة بالنسبة لي، أن يمن الله عليّ
بشيء كهذا في بداية عملي
كان دفعةً قوية جدًا.
فبدأت بالتفكير،
ما هي الطرق المتاحة أمامي.
وجدتني أمام ثلاثة طرق:
أولهم، وكانت أكثرهم خبره،
أن أبحث عن عمل بالخارج.
ولكن دعوني أخبركم بشيء،
أنا قولت أنه من الاستحالة أن أترك بلدي
أمزح بالطبع، كانت متطلباتهم
أعلى من خبرتي فلم أستطع التقديم.
الطريق الثاني والمنطقي، أن أبحث
عن الشركات المتواجدة في مصر
والتي تعمل في تطوير الألعاب
لكن للأسف، معظم الشركات في مصر تعمل بmodel
يسمى business to business أو B2B
تجد نفسك 60% من الوقت مثلًا
-ليس كل الوقت لأكون صريحًا-
60% من الوقت تعمل على لعبة
لشركة دعايا وإعلان
فتجد مثلًا client من شركة عصير
يخبرك بأن تصنع game وrunner
وأضف بعض الcoins،
فلتنسى الـgame design وذلك الكلام الفارغ،
فتجد نفسك أنك لا تصنع لعبة؛
الـlearn curve خاصتك بطيء جدًا
تتعلم أشياء على فترات متباعدة
والحقيقة أنا لا أقدر على لوم أصحاب الشركات
على اتباعهم لهذا الmodel،
لأنه له الحق أن يبحث عن الطريقة
اللي تجعل شركته ناجحه وتستطيع الاستمرار.
لكن ذلك لم يكن أفضل model بالنسبة لي؛
ولذلك اخترت الطريق الثالث:
اخترت أن أكون Indie Game Developer
هل لعب أحدكم indie games من قبل؟
أو يعلم معنى indie game development؟
جميل جدًا
- ربنا معاك
[يضحك]
Okay
كلمة indie مشتقة من independent
ببساطة شديدة،
الفكرة تخطرعلى بالك، نفذها،
من غير أي قيود،
من غير شروط لابد أن تكون في الـproduct
لأنك أنت الوحيد
المسؤول عن أي شيء في اللعبة،
من أول الفكرة،
مرورًا بتطويرها وتنفيذها، حتى التسويق
والحقيقة الصناعة المستقلة ليست حكرًا
على الألعاب، موجودة في الأفلام
في الـmusic إن كان أحد منكم
يسمع underground bands
كل هؤلاء يعتبروا indies.
الشيء الجميل الأخر
في الـindie development
أن أسلوب العمل نفسه مختلف
وليس الفكرة فقط
أنت لا تحتاج إلى مكان لتعمل فيه،
يمكنك أنت تعمل في cafe،
يمكنك أن تعلم في منزل صديقك.
ممكن game كاملة
يكون الفريق الذي صنعها مكون من فردين
artist و developer
أعجبوا بفكرة معينة فقرروا أن ينفذوها
من الممكن أن يكونوا من بلدين مختلفين،
فتجد نفسك تكسر حواجز كان من الاستحالة
أن تكسرها لو عملت في شركة عادية.
سأحااول أن أقرب لكم الفكرة أكثر
سأريكم prototype لـgame
نعمل عليها حاليًا
اسمها Secrets of a Bonfire
كل واحد منّا عنده أسرار
وكثير منّا يحتاج أن يجلس في عزلة
ليتحدث مع نفسه قليلًا
هذا بالظبط الـmood اللي الذي
أن نضعه في Secret of a Bonfire
أنت تذهب لتخيم في مكانٍ وحدك
منك للطبيعة
وتقف أمام bonfire تشعلها
وتقعد تحكي secret
احكي سر أي شيء يخطر على دماغك
وبعد ذلك تتختار:
إما أن تحرق السر،
فلا أحد غيرك يعرفه
أو هناك option أخر،
الحقيقة الـoption الأخر غير موجود
حتى الآن في الـprototype
لكني سأحكي لكم ما الذي سيحدث
لو اخترت الـoption الأخر
تستطيع أن تأخذك سرك،
وتضعه في زجاجة، وتلقيها في البحر
أتعرفون رسائل البحر؟ هي نفس الفكرة بالظبط
حينها فقط، تستطيع أن تقرأ secret
يخصplayer أخر لا تعرفه
ولن تقابله طوال حياتك.
نحن اثنان فقط نعمل عل هذه اللعبة
الهدف الوحيد منها أننا نريد للاعب
أن يعيش تجربةً معينة
لكي يشعر أنها it's more than just a game
هذا هو هدفنا.
جعلتكم تحبون الـindie game development،
حان الوقت لأصدمكم،
الحقيقة اننا كـindie studio
نواجه ثلاث صعوبات،
أولهم أنه قبل أن تطلق اللعبة
وتحقق نجاح باهر،
أنت في حاجة للنقود، تحتاج salary،
لكي تستطيع أن تنفق على مشروعك
وتستطيع أن تنفق على معيشتك.
فتجدأن مضطر أن تعمل عملًا أخر
لتحصل على تلك النقود، ولكن خذ حذرك،
يجب أن تعرف جيدًا
أن ذلك العمل سيستهلك وقت
فيجب أن تعلم مدة هذا الوقت
لكي لا تجد نفسك تنجرف عن هذفك الأساسي
الذي تريد تحقيقه.
انتهيت من اللعبة وأطدرتها،
أنت indie game developer
مما يعني أنك ستقوم بالتسويق
ولابد أن تعلم جيدًا أن ذلك سيستهلك
وقت ومجهود ونقود،
أو أن تبحث عن أحد ليمولك
ويأخذ حصة من الأرباح مثلًا.
[يتنهد]
النقطة الثالثة،
وأنا صراحة لا أحب أن أتحدث في تلك النقطة
مع مصريين لأن دمي يفور
لكني سأحاول أن أتمالك أعصابي
بأمانة،
كام شخص هنا اشترى software؟
شكرًا
للأسف عندنا في مصر ثقافة:
"لماذا اشتريه وهو موجود على الانترنت ومجانًا"
بالرغم من أننا ندفع أمولًا في أشياء كثيرة أخرى،
نحن ندفع أمولًا في ملابس،
نحن أفضل من ينفق على الأكل.
فـ"تريدني أن أشتري software؟
أجننت أم ماذا؟ ولعبة؟!"
سأقص عليكم قصة،
في فترة بدأت
في نشر عدوى شراء الألعاب،
فجاءتني قريبة لي وقالت: "أتصح
تلك الأشياء الخاطئة التي علمتها للود؟
أتجعله يدفع 500 جنية في لعبة؟!"
حضرتك هو عمل الشيء الصحيح!
هو اشتراها بدلًا من أن..
يأخذها من غير نقود،
لا أريد أن أقول كلمةً أخرى.
الفكرة أنه لو دفع هذه النقود لشراء حذاء
لما تذمر أحد،
أعيد التفكير مرتين
قبل أن تقوم بكسر حماية أي لعبة،
بالأخص لو كانت indie game،
لأن هناك أناس كثيرون جدًا في مصر
يستحقون التشجيع لتقوم هذه الصناعة،
وجزء كبير من تلك الصناعة يعتمد عليكم.
والجدير بالذكر أنا هناك الكثير
من الناس في مصر تريد أن تدخل هذا المجال.
هناك حدث عالمي
يحدث في نفس الوقت في العالم أجمع
يسمى Global Game Jam
فكرته أنه لديك ثلاثة أيام
لتصنع فيهم لعبة،
في آخر سنتين، مصر كانت أكبرموقع في هذا الحدث
وثالث يوم في السنتين السابقتين
يقدم تقريبا 90 عرض لألعاب
فهذا معناه أن هناك جيل
من الـindie developers يريدون أن ينطلقوا
فيستحقون أن تشجعهم.
أكتر ما يعجبني في الـjam
أنك قد تلاقي ولد عمره 14 أو 15 سنة،
لا يعلم شيئًا عن المجال
ولكنه قَدِمَ ليتعلم،
لم يهمه رأي "أنت لازلت صغيًرا،
عندما تكبر ستفهم تلك الأشياء"
أنا مقتنع بأن كلام الناس
لا يفعل شيء سوى تعطيلك.
عندما قررت أن أكون game developer
لم يهمني ماذا قال الناس
لم يهمني رأيهم.
لكن أتعلمون ما الذي أحدث الفارق فعلًا؟
رد فعل والدي ووالدتي.
كم أب أو أم هنا أولادهم
في مرحلة الثانوية العامة أو كلية
المرحلة التي تُتَخذ
فيها قرارات تخص مستقبلهم؟
أريدكم أن تسألوا أنفسكم سؤال
واحتفظوا بالإجابة لأنفسكم:
أنتم بنسبة كم تقريبًا تتركوا لأولادكم
أن يتخذوا قرارتهم بأنفسهم؟
من أكثر الأشياء التي استغربتها صرحةً
رد فعل والدي ووالدتي
لما شرحت لهم الـgame development
وأن ذلك هو الشيء الذي اخترته،
حتى لو لم يستوعبوها 100%
لم أجد منهم غير رد واحد فقط:
"ربنا يوفقك"
شعرت وقتها بثقتهم فيَّ
شعرت أنهم واثقين
أني سأنجح في الشيء الذي أحب
ولم يكن بإمكاني أن أفرط في هذه الثقة
من المؤكد أنكم تعرفون أن هناك
فرق جيل بينكم وبين أولادكم
فمن المنطقي أن طريقة التفكير أو الاهتمامات
أن تكون مختلفة
لكن يجب أن تعرفوا جيدًا
الوقت الذي تتركوهم
ليتخذوا قراراتهم بأنفسهم
متى يحين الوقت لتتركوهم يخطئوا
ليتعلموا من أخطائهم
وصدقوني لن يخذلوكم
لأن أظن كوني واقف هنا أمامكم
يعني أنني لم أخذلهم.
شكرًا.
[تصفيق]